how's it going guys matt here from
codetech editorials we're going to be
looking at dijkstra's algorithm and
today i'm just going to kind of go over
it in like a lecture type form and we're
going to walk through an example
and then a later episode uh maybe some
kind of bonus midweek episode or
something we're going to code it up and
make an example that you might use in an
actual game or something but today we
just want to get an understanding of the
algorithm
because i don't know about you but i
when i read dijkstra's from an
algorithms book i had to re-read it like
three times
all the math stuff and it seemed very
complicated but really it's quite a
simple and somewhat beautiful little
algorithm so we're gonna make it as
simple as possible the goal is really
for it to just kind of stick in your
head
and
you to be able to apply it a little bit
after watching this so that's the main
goal all right well let's jump into the
blackboard dijkstra's algorithm
d i j this is often used in well
all over the place uh initially of
course you might think it's used in
games but it's also well it's using
games of course for pathfinding
but it's also used for other stuff too
including like network traffic and
basically any sort of traffic any sort
of traffic that has to pick different
directions and try to find the best way
they often use dijkstra's there are
other algorithms too i'm not saying this
is the only one but it is a very common
one and it is pretty efficient i believe
it is n log n
and we might go over that more later it
is a very greedy approach which we might
talk a little bit more about later but
let's go ahead and set up an example map
so you need a map or a graph
not the the map from c plus plus with an
actual maps so we're just gonna make
some nodes all right so i got a bit of a
palette here just these three colors to
use i think that should be enough
alright so let's make a map let's go
ahead and just define some nodes here
and see what we can basically come up
with here let's stick with letters
we'll make this node a
and maybe we'll make a b down here
a c over here and we're going to connect
these up a d over here e over here
maybe an f down here
now this setup doesn't matter a whole
lot
the way it's displayed visually doesn't
matter a whole lot
uh it's just we gotta make some sort of
example we also need
i'm gonna use uh a column here so this
might be defined as like
each of these rows might be something
like a node struct
so you have each of these right
this is obviously what the node is named
the second column i guess you would call
it like an efficiency we call it the
shortest distance from the starting
point now we are going to define the
starting point
as a now you don't necessarily have to
do that but
you have a starting point always right
every time you run this algorithm and
what this algorithm does
is it runs from your start
and then to your finish so you also need
to know where you're going or where you
want to go let's make some dots here for
these
dots usually if you build this as a
function you pass in
the entire graph
and then a start and a finish and it
runs it from there we haven't drew the
lines yet clearly
but if this were some sort of map maybe
you have some objects you're not aware
of like maybe maybe there's a canyon
here or something with no bridge or
river so there's no cross in that or if
you do cross it it's very expensive
uh and maybe if you go straight from a
to d
uh it's
a nice long straight stretch
but uh
you know there's a lot of scenarios and
that's where the weights come in last
column is the previous vertex
okay so when you set up this algorithm
let's go ahead and just define this
graph now i am going to do this like
randomly basically some other random
connections here
we'll make like a g because i want to
have some some varying cases basically
so that you can really see it work so
now it's starting to look a little
map like we've got some different
options all of these we'll call them
roads
these connections
all have a weight or a difficulty on a
map this might be like how many miles it
is
or
on a game it might be how difficult is
the grid cell
is it quicksand is it water or is it
simple terrain you know that's it's
something like that and basically we
assign it a number so let's say going
straight from a to f that this one's
super difficult so we're going to give
it a 10 and we also need to add g to
this little thing here
so we'll do that real quick and we
should probably put some titles i
believe the setup is actually rather
important i think part partially the
setup is what helps it stick in your
brain a lot now let's say
that we want to go
just for this particular example
of course you could pick anything we're
going to assume that the start is a and
we're going to assume the finish is e
we're attempting to get to e nice crayon
drawing there so the goal is to get from
a to e in the cheapest way possible
and in a very simple graph you're going
to be able to just sample up these
numbers and probably eyeball it and be
able to tell but what happens when it's
really complicated or when you do need
to do it a million times over and over
a bunch of times a frame or
it's network traffic and there's no way
you can eyeball it
that's the point of this algorithm so in
this example you're going to look at it
and think oh that's obviously the
shortest path but
the point is the algorithm not that you
can eyeball this simple example let's
fill these out we're going to be calling
this distance but it's not necessarily
always called distance sometimes it's
called like difficulty or something like
that but it is an edge that goes from
one node to another and we are also
assuming that these can go
both ways that you can go
back or forth but for our cases
generally we're always going to go
forward here you typically don't want to
visit a node and then go back actually
it doesn't even allow that as we'll see
shortly
when you start now this is a minimizing
algorithm basically means it's gonna
it's gonna minimize your options it's
gonna take away all the bad options and
you're gonna be only left with the best
and
when you visit
nodes you visit the one
with the smallest distance from a
next and you just keep doing that until
you visited all of them so what this
ends up meaning is that you have
an open set and a closed set so the
unvisited set is all these basically
that's a start things you haven't been
to so let's go ahead and put that in
here
okay there we go so we have an unvisited
set
and a visited set as we visit a node and
do all the calculations for that node
we're going to move it to the visited
and we never visit it again oh we need
to do one more thing the distance from a
so may we're going to make the
assumption here
that if we don't know we're going to
call it it's infinity distance we have
no idea in theory as far as we know
since we haven't checked it might be
impossible so we are going to assume
impossibility except for a the distance
from a to a
is obviously zero
because we're already there that is
important for the calculation
and the rest of these is considered to
be infinity
keep that in mind i'm going to leave
them blank if this is blank here assume
infinity
got it
because that's what we start these out
as you start them out as like the
highest possible value because we'll
need that for comparison shortly
so let's start the algorithm and i'll
walk through it now when we start with a
you want to compare
all the edges we can go from a to g
we can go from a to b or we can go to
eight f and they each have their weights
if we check this one we get the value
four we check this one we get the value
seven
if we check this one we get the value
10.
now all we do here is we check and see
if the value to each of these is higher
or lower okay so we look at g we can see
that
going to g from a takes seven
so that's clearly lower than infinity
thus we fill it in
and we see that going from a to b
is four
which is also lower than infinity so in
the b node
we fill out a 4.
and we can see that going from a to f is
10. we are now done with a so we move a
from the unvisited set to the visited
set but now what we do is we go to the
next minimum value on this chart
so a is done
we'll do a little red here so we look at
this one because 4 is less than 10 and 7
and all the infinity we don't count the
0 anymore because it's
visited we're only looking at the
unvisited lowest b
being 4 is the lowest so we work with b
next so looking at b
b can also
go to f
right here
b can also go to g
right here and b can also go to c
so we update all those
but we do take in account this 4 value
that b currently has
so if we're going let's look at the f
first f's current value is 10 but coming
from b
it is four
plus two which equals six
you see that so now this f
oh i'm sorry i missed one critical thing
last time the previous vert
now anytime you update these numbers
you also update the vertices it just
came from obviously these all came from
a
that was the previous vertex on those
values so anytime you update it you also
update
that
so now going from b to f
we get a total of six six is lower than
ten so we fill that out and update the
lowest vert
so this is now going to be a six
and this is now going to be a b this is
6 and it came from b last
and we can go to g and check check out g
so 4
5 6 7
7
is the same
so this actually
brings up a case where you kind of have
to choose okay so if they are the same
it doesn't matter in that case we are
going to leave it we are not going to
update g we are going to leave it
the same and then we also want to look
at from b to c
b to c well c is currently infinity
so we're going to calculate it up with a
4
plus an 8
and it looks like we get 12 in this case
so to get the c
it's going to take 12
and we came from b and we are done with
this iteration we've updated what we can
update
and everything's good and we're done
visiting b
b can be added
to the list of visited notes so now we
want to go to the next lowest
so it looks like out of 12 6 7 and a
couple infinities that six is the lowest
so we're going to go to the six
now 6 is an f note
f note doesn't go anywhere it's kind of
in a corner
so there's actually no work to do we've
already visited b and a and we already
have those values we moved it to the
visited let's check the next one we've
only got c and g and there are 12 and a
seven
well the seven is obviously lower so
we're going to go to g
and from g we can see that we can get 2d
and we can see that we can get to c
now going from g
to d
takes whatever the current value of g is
which is seven
plus six
so we get 13 to get to d hey that's
lower than infinity so we got something
to work with here so we put a 13 here
and we say the last node visited
was g
and we can see that going from g to c oh
i didn't give this one a value a random
number seven so we can see from going
from g to c is the current value of g
which is seven and then plus another
seven so it's going to be 14
and it looks like that's not the
shortest path
it's uh because 14 is not lower than 12
thus we're uh we're not going to update
it we already have a shorter path so we
don't want to know we're just going to
get that one out of here with this
minification
but at this point we have checked both
those nodes we're done with g
and we can just update accordingly or
move it to the visited set and then
there we go we see c d and e left
so if you're doing this in code
obviously you need
these variables and you're going to need
some pair comparisons but
second episode be sure to subscribe if
you don't want to miss the coding up of
this in an example so all right let's
visit the next lowest we've got c and d
so the 12 is the lowest and that's at c
all right so we want to check all of c's
paths now c can go to d
or c can go to e
and we take c's value 12
and add one to go to this d
and we can see that we get another 13.
13 is the same
so it doesn't matter what we do we could
take it we cannot take it we just have
to pick one in my case in my particular
algorithm i'm going to say if they're
the same we're going to leave it
but you could just as well say to take
it all the time if it's better it
doesn't really matter in this case this
is a greedy algorithm
so
you're making optimal choices
every iteration you're not looking
at the end goal ahead of time
that would be more of a depth first
search which is less efficient but might
give you a better end result
so since this is a greedy algorithm it's
not necessarily going to get you the
best end result it's going to get you
the best result locally per node
and when you add them all together you
very often get
a very good result
or very cheap so that's that's the point
of it that's why it's used in
pathfinding because it's very cheap you
could do a depth first every time with
your game but oh boy is it going to chug
when things are pathfinding they'll
pathfind well but it's going to chug
it's going to have a hard time getting
there
all right let's go ahead and do this
so we're not going to update that we're
going to leave that one
the same
all right let's look from c to e now e
is infinity so we can update we're going
to add c's 12
plus this new 5
and that will turn into 17
and we last came from c
and now we can mark off c because we're
done with it and now the next lowest is
d
so from d we only have one path and it
is so boom to e
so we take d's current value of 13
and add the four
and we get
17. so we see we got kind of a little
conflict of a path but we're going to
leave it because that's what we're doing
in our case and there we go we've now
visited these okay the very last one we
have is our end goal
and that is e now obviously we already
know
uh all these paths there's no new paths
just like it was with f but we do
still visit these even just because hey
they're still
in this unvisited set
it has now been visited you can just
mark it
and we have
what i would call our result so now we
have our path it's done so we've we've
completed this run if we passed
and let's say if we made a function we
passed it this graph and said we want to
go from here to here
this is what it would generate
and you're done for that iteration
final
uh pack
we want to know which nodes to visit
because obviously we got to move our guy
right so when you start moving your guy
this is how you do it you basically want
to pile this on from the end so if we
look at e
well that one's clearly the end then we
need to know what node is before that
but luckily we just have that right and
we can see that the previous vert is c
right before
you put a c you can go to c
and see that the previous vert is b
so you make a you put a b before that so
we go to b and we can see that b comes
from a so you can see now we're back at
the start this is our final path this is
the best path
everything else is eliminated so at this
point we could draw it out but
essentially you would move your guy
along this path now every frame this is
the thing every frame or after every
move
if things have changed like if your end
goal has changed maybe maybe you're
trying to track some other object in
your object move to d for example
you would have to run it again
so if if it's tracking a moving object
like you know enemy
ally versus enemy type thing in a game
you have to do this every time but if
it's for a map
that's a static map that's not going to
change
or your end goal is not going to change
then you can just run through the whole
thing hope that makes sense
but that's just to make it super obvious
so let's go from a
to b
then from b
to c and then we go from
c to e and just like that we've
completed the shortest path
see if you can code this up uh there are
some good examples online there are a
ton of examples this is a very famous
algorithm there's a million other videos
but hopefully this explanation
is thorough enough for it to like really
click and stick in your head that's
that's the true goal of this
and hopefully i've accomplished that
goal if i even came close consider
hitting that like button and stay tuned
now i just want to say thank you for
watching and for helping support my
channel just watching means a lot if you
want to go the extra mile
you can
well there's plenty of buttons they're
all over the place you can join you can
give thanks
a thumbs up is is awesome that's that's
the main thing i'm always looking for
because it helps with the algorithm and
all that stuff but if you're willing to
spare a couple bucks to help me keep
making these sort of tutorials and you
know code technotorial type stuff
consider
supporting on patreon for as little as
three bucks a month you can keep my
livelihood
uh improving while i'm doing this
and uh i thank you immensely alright
we'll see you in the next one peace out
guys
[Music]
i have an error here don't i no i don't
never mind i was 3 and 7 is 10. so i was
looking at this and thinking
this is cheaper but obviously it's not
because it's 10 total
if we go to g anyway a little side point
that my brain just decided was a good
idea to bring up
[Music]